it's burger time
[Music]
for me there's nothing more nostalgic
than a cheeseburger but i know i'm not
the only person who feels this way so
today we're reaching out to some experts
to answer this question
what is your favorite burger from your
childhood what is the burger that pulls
on your heartstrings so get ready as
tasty's chef rye
and the legend wolfgang pup take you
down memory lane and of course your
boy's got something up his sleeve too
[Music]
hi i'm maria from tasty and i'm so
excited to be on the burger show
i like baking a lot i make a lot of
pastry for tasty page
but today i'm so excited to make
teriyaki burger so teriyaki burger is
something nostalgic to me i'm from japan
and i grown up
very rural area
and i didn't have any burger chain
restaurant when i went to high school i
went to a little bit city side so
every saturday me and my friends go out
and eat burgers for lunch if you go to
japanese burger chain like mcdonald's or
moss burger you can find a teriyaki
burger everywhere in japan we have this
dish called hambagu which is japanese
salisbury
steak and i grown up eating this hambagu
all the time so i kind of wanted to make
pate
it's kind of like a hambagu but teriyaki
burger all right so first thing you want
to work on is patty in japan it is
usually half and half of ground beef and
ground pork now i'm going to soak panko
with milk
and i'm putting ground beef and ground
pork and season with salt and pepper
add
soaked panko and egg
mixed together
purest people
maybe jasping right now go time
adding so much ingredients i don't have
title as a burger scholar
and i'm going to shape this into kind of
thin patty i think i can make two
here
now i'm going to put a little bit oil
like smash so it kind of gives a nice
crust on the bottom
yeah the juice is clear
i think it's great
i'm going to rest
the pate and i'm moving on to
the sauce it's kind of inspired by my
mom's
sauce that she makes chicken wings with
sake
and meeting
we use meeting a lot for japanese
cooking it kind of gives nice glaze i'm
also adding sugar
and soy sauce
and i'm adding a little bit garlic while
it's reducing i'm going to toast buns i
like brioche because it's kind of rich
and buttery put some butter
and toast it until it's
golden brown in japanese we call
kitsunero which is
fox color
okay put a little bit mayo on the bottom
cupid is
something like staple mile for japanese
household put this burger
in the sauce
it kind of covers
but let us
going to pour extra sauce
and mayo
here we have it
my
childhood
memory laying teriyaki burger
oh
saucy
crunchness from the iceberg lettuce
and kind of char the bottom of the
burger kind of salty and sweet it's all
you want
like
juicy i feel like now i'm hanging out
with my friends thank you so much for
watching and chef wolfgang park
take it away
i did not grow up in austria eating
hamburgers or cheeseburgers you know
there was no burger chains in austria or
anything quite like that so i grew up
with wienerschnitzel and we made a
wienerschnitzel burger i could call it
the veena schnitzel sandwich or even
schnitzel pelican sprout how we would
say it in german but i think for me it's
better than any hamburger in the world
my mother made it for me
on sunday lunch not for me for the whole
family if you don't know what the winner
is let me tell you now win
is the capital of austria in america we
call it vienna so vino schnitzel is
a scalopini which is spreaded in flour
egg and bread crumbs and fried to
perfection now i'm gonna show you how my
mom did it and the way i still do it
today most important part is
you pound your meat really thin wheel is
really the best way you put your meat in
a
ziploc bag like i have here and then you
pound it gently
so this is really important we want it
thin but not too thin
then
we have to season it salt
and also pepper fresh ground pepper
always now if you have a pepper mill you
have to go like this this you push with
the butter this is america my mother
didn't have that are you ready i'm going
to show you how we bread the wine
schnitzel all right okay here we have
the meat
i'm gonna put it first in flour on both
sides
okay
a little spanking oh you like that huh
okay
and then we're gonna put it in the egg
cover it on both sides
and then
last but not least we're gonna put it in
the breadcrumbs
unfortunately i immigrated to
indianapolis or i should say fortunately
there
they had a chain called white castle
and they made hamburgers and i said what
the [ __ ] is that a square meat body in a
roll i said okay i'm done with the
hamburger i'm going back to my venus so
it's much better i love brioche buns so
we're going to put it on a griddle here
okay i'm going to make the dressing for
my
slow a little bit of the mayonnaise
some white wine vinegar
mix it together
i'll add a little olive oil
all right we're gonna put a little sugar
in here this is traditional middle
european cooking where a lot of things
are sweet and sour we're gonna mix our
cabbage the white cabbage
the red cabbage
you know it's great to have it to have a
little color
a few cucumbers for crunchiness
extra crunchiness
and some carrots and if you like bell
peppers a few peppers
perfect we ready to fry
let's check one more time the
temperature my mother did not have a
temperature a tomato like this like we
have here what did you do she used a
little leaf of cabbage and throw it in
there now when you fry a schnitzel be
careful when you put it in the oil so
always put it in tower dew
and then let it drip to the other side
slowly don't throw it in like that so
always away from you you can see this it
starts to swim
okay and we move the oil a little bit
so that way
the
spreading fluffs up a little bit
all right you can see how nice and
crispy it is that's really an important
part
i love the smell all right now we're
gonna assemble it we're gonna use some
coleslaw all right
just like that
squeeze a little lemon juice on it
then
comes my favorite
a little bit of the lingonberry so this
is a little sweet and sour you know we
didn't have ketchup in austria but we
had a lot of price repair and we picked
them in the forest and my mother made
marmalade out of it i didn't see ketchup
i don't know until i was probably 20
years old
my venus schnitzel burger here squeeze
it nice together
[Music]
you know what i remember the most
about my childhood at least the good
part is the food the food my mother used
to make for us
um
now i'm grown up
what we're gonna have a little
australian wine with it
[Music]
[Music]
perfect you all see what is on the front
here how are you all doing well we are
doing amazing because we are having a
venus in sir but look at the back
what the what does it
what the [ __ ] does it say on the back i
can read on my back don't get too crazy
if you do call me
alvin take it away you won't get the
pinot sensor like that anywhere
[Music]
hi i'm alvin kailan of the burger show
welcome to my home today we're making
the sunday gravy burger i actually make
a big pot of red sauce
every sunday
it's inspired by my love for mafia
movies and usually when we have
leftovers i turn them into burgers and
that's what i'm making today so i want
to take you back to that time in my life
i was a young
hungry cook
i worked you know 12 hour days i got
paid three dollars an hour
so you know when i get home i'd be super
tired and i would make this burger right
here now i'm going to show you how it's
done you already have all of this stuff
in your refrigerator you have the red
sauce maybe you have prego or ragu in
your refrigerator that works too you
have pesto you have parmigiano reggiano
compound butter burgers fresh mutts
provolone and a nice hoagie roll you
slice it but you don't go all the way
through
you leave it hinged so what we have is
this garlic compound butter it's
literally just garlic
parsley
garlic kung fi or roasted garlic
and fresh garlic you just smear the
butter on
and then you're just gonna sprinkle
parmesan cheese first step
to this smash burger
is
getting your meatball
and
rolling it in parmigiano reggiano it
creates a really good crust and it's
phenomenal it's like one of the best
tasting things you can do i'm gonna do
these one at a time because you you want
to focus on the crust that this makes
all right we're gonna give it a flip
bam
hey look at this [ __ ] in my eye get over
here check this out
two more times
[Music]
all right so now that the patties are
done we're gonna
toast our garlic bread
just like that look at listen oh look at
how he looked
oh that's burnt
i'm gonna flip this back down boom look
at that
gorgeous
gorgeous i have this
sunday gravy that took all day to make
we're gonna put it on the bottom of this
roll we have green sauce aka pesto for
the top part of the roll we're gonna put
our patties down
shingle it some provolone cheese
fresh nuts
we're gonna grab the torch
and then what we've all been waiting for
cross section check this out
look at that
sunday gravy burger by yours truly look
how good that looks looks [ __ ] great
right make this at home go ahead go
ahead look at that cross section we have
the colors of the italian flag
[Music]
that's a good burger we have a super
tasty tomato sauce
the pesto adds mad freshness
the cheese who doesn't like fresh
mozzarella
it's so good
and the parmesan smashed into the burger
patty i promise you you've never had
anything like that
and you're welcome but best of all this
reminds me of being a kid just being
adventurous
being creative and really that's what
this burger's about so
give it a try i promise it won't let you
down
forget about it
[Music]
hello again i hope you enjoyed this
segment of the show
and remember don't get too crazy if you
do call me
[Music]
what's up y'all it's your boy alvin
kylon of the burger show make sure you
like
subscribe and hit that notification bell
if not for me
for the burger